president biden's proving he's totally
clueless and americans aren't having it
anymore joe biden turning a blind eye to
the problems plaguing the country
including rising gas prices massive
inflation and an energy crisis all being
made worse by his policies the white
house now playing cleanup after getting
called out over a plan to shut down that
pipeline in michigan it now says it's
only reviewing building a new one
and when it comes to the pain at the
pump the white house basically telling
americans too bad just deal with it
we're very concerned about the impact of
high energy prices on consumers
especially as we enter the colder months
we just don't have anything right now to
to announce but like i said we're
monitoring this and we're we're working
through what is it that how we can
actually address this republican
lawmaker jim jordan torching biden over
the higher prices saying this is all by
design
what do these guys want eight dollar gas
you had the big oil uh company
executives in there from uh from chevron
exxon bp we had him in there and ro
connor was badgering these guys saying
will you commit to reducing production
so joe biden begs opec to increase
production and democrat members of
congress badger american companies to
decrease production i mean this makes no
sense
and americans are losing faith in biden
fast a new poll shows that over half say
biden hasn't even been focusing on
issues that actually matter greg you
brought this up the other day this is by
design the higher prices i think it was
you someone that looked like you yeah
it's worth reminding people this is what
joe biden said about phasing out fossil
fuels run it
we are going to get rid of fossil fuels
they want to do the same thing i want to
do they want to phase out fossil fuels
and we're going to phase out fossil
fuels
you think this is part of the plan
yeah i think if you have a less
independent population uh due to an
economic crisis they're more dependent
on the government we even saw that with
covid the free money it was a kind of an
accelerated version of that
i know that it's five o'clock so i need
to get permission to be really
disgusting
i never really asked for permission but
i figured i would now and the producers
probably aren't even listening right
they're probably just getting their
coffee and said they have no idea so
what joe's saying is he doesn't want you
to pay attention to what's going on he's
always passing the buck right he's not
taking responsibility but we had a
saying back in third grade you know what
that was whoever smelt it
dealt it it may be silent but it's
deadly he's the guy that always lets one
fly in an elevator and then assumes if
nobody else if he doesn't react no one
else will react either even though the
stench of his white house is
overpowering he releases more gas than
opec maybe that's why he doesn't think
we need more energy but the big thing is
you see msnbc saying inflation is a good
thing cnn's saying oh joe can't do much
about this it's out of his hands it's
unusual and weird to see the media say
what can you do about stuff when they
spend so much time saying you must do
something whether it's climate you must
do something whether it's gun control
you m it must you must do something but
here it is people have to pay more for
food gas and oil it's like ah not so
fast it's really not on him and i think
that goes back to what what i said that
they want a society that's more
dependent on government and that's why
this is not that big of a deal i wish
joe was doing nothing but like you said
in the opening he's actively destroying
our energy sector has got gas prices
soar cutting off pipelines that's like
basically removing you know your
children's playground set as the kid
gains weight you know it's this is not
helpful it's funny you're right the
democrats have finally found the one
thing they can't control yeah energy
production i thought you guys say
farting in elevators yes would you like
i was going to go to dana why don't i
move over here
how do you pay attention to his pretty
intellectual discourse after he starts
it with flatulence no that's what grabs
your attention and then you
try it's the combination of the two
that's right the snarly hook
your thoughts on what we're seeing right
now with this administration i think
it's most i think afghanistan is very
instructive because in afghanistan they
had good intentions and they didn't ask
backwards instead of evacuating the
civilians first they evacuated the
military civilians stuck they had to
re-redo and i think the same thing is
happening with fossil fuels they want to
eliminate fossil fuels they cut down on
the supply of fossil fuels
in furtherance of that goal way before
the alternative has been developed it's
not ready so it's it's again it's ass
backwards first you develop first you
want everyone to have a tesla then you
could get rid of fossil fuel to do it
now when it drives at the price of the
pump i think that that is problematic
and i think that that is very
instructive of his if his thought
process and how they are reacting almost
in in knee-jerk fashion to whatever it
is it's very improvisational and uh i
find it distressing ass backwards dagon
yeah i'm all for that um
usually
um the fact that biden and his liberal
cadre they
in the past have been so slavish to the
polls and so reactionary remember last
in the summer of 2020 when the polls
started moving against him on the
rioting both harris and biden came out
in august and said oh we
we've denounced violence even though it
had been going on for weeks couple of
months at least but now they don't seem
to care about the polls
which is hugely troubling and
frightening so what they see is they're
going to ignore the polls and they see
this even ignore the election the losses
in virginia because they see this window
closing now they've got one year to push
through this incredibly divisive but
left-wing agenda this scary-ass world
view that imposes that they're imposing
their will on the country whether it's
forcing people through higher prices to
use alternative energy they're gonna
spend four trillion dollars more to
create this giant new century welfare
monstrosity it's all about not just
bigger government but more centralized
government europe on steroids and
certainly more power to those in power
already a scorched earth approach to
getting their way and i'll just point to
last month and it's not just necessarily
at the federal level gretchen whitmer
tried to um last year shut down this
it's a four and a half mile stretch of
this line five pipeline it is a
a she was trying to terminate this
easement and canada last month had to
invoke a treaty
to stop it this sends fuel not into just
the united states but fuel chip heat and
gas up the cars in ontario and quebec
they hate canada
yeah and they were supposed to be um
very diplomatic compared to the previous
president they claimed so that's a great
point they were very nimble when it came
to the polling and at least
acting like they cared about public
sentiment in the election and now
they're just like ah
go wall i've seen this on many issues
one of them was afghanistan remember one
of their solution on afghanistan was to
say well it was the largest airlift in
history and also everyone will forget
about this in a month that didn't happen
uh they're doing this on immigration
they're they they are in the teens in
immigration in the polling and they
still are like yeah we're not doing
anything on that and then the midterm
ads write themselves because basically
what they've done is say
we're not going to pay attention to
things you care about even though people
are saying these are the things we care
about and they still ignore them and
there's today they're pushing this 500
billion dollars for climate change
issues well people are actually talking
about the high price of gas and
groceries and then they have this grab
bag of policies and it's like if your
mom gave you twenty dollars and said go
to the store and get some groceries for
the family and you go and you get two
six packs of beer and some magazine you
come home and it's like no the family's
still hungry
and what the deputy press secretary said
today was that we have no specifics on
that and they won't and this is a story
that's not going to go away like in
afghanistan it's not on the front pages
but it's still in people's minds
winter's just beginning
and you see you've got a long way ahead
if grand home just said 54 increase for
your heating oil costs you think that's
not going to reverberate through the
whole country and also it takes a while
for supply and demand to work itself out
on
energy issues and they're not doing
anything to increase supply except for
asking opec to help that's a bad
position to be in two six-packs
and a couple of magazines that's my
thanksgiving
it's affordable
you know and your family's upset yeah
yeah
global warming might bail them out all
right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else